what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and
i just watched
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and i just watched
obi-wan kenobi the kenobi series now i'm
at star wars celebration disney flew me
out here um big shout out to them for
really really taking care of me um it's
been a great experience so far this is
my first star wars celebration so uh
it's quite an experience uh big shout
out to them
they let us watch it early although i
just found out so right now i don't know
i think it's like around 9 30 uh pacific
time i just found out that they released
op1 early so as i'm talking everybody
can watch it right now this is going to
come out tomorrow morning
but i just watched it at star wars
celebration they did a premiere for it
then i got to
attend thankfully thanks to disney and
i loved
kenobi i loved the first two episodes of
kenobi i thought it was insanely cool i
i haven't felt this much like star wars
in a while i like the mandalorian i like
boba fett
a lot i really like the mandalorian um
but this to me really really really felt
like star wars and i know i talk about
marvel on my channel
that's not changing so don't worry for
all the marvel fans that's definitely
not changing daily marvel content but i
love star wars like i love star wars um
so i'm happy to
to do more star wars content
especially with everything they have
coming up but kenobi
like the okay let's talk about just the
opening scene of episode one
right to order 66 in the jedi temple
this scene to me
was like one of the greatest star wars
scenes of all time like i truly believe
that too one of the greatest star wars
scenes of all time i thought it was just
awesome i love cd i love seeing jedi
like fight storm troopers
i don't know why like that's just some
that's just very star wars to me uh
storm troopers and jedi and you know i
just love that so much um
but that opening scene right away i was
like star wars like i feel like this
isn't like this is this is star wars
that we haven't gotten
in a bit
and it just felt really good and it just
felt really cool and i really really
loved it and i oh my gosh
the casting is just amazing of this
little little princess leia is like the
cutest thing ever it's like so cool
that that's what we're seeing and i you
know i didn't really know much going in
to this of course i've seen the trailers
and everything like that but
i didn't really know it's gonna be so
much about leia i thought it was gonna
be more more about luke and you know i
didn't realize it's kenobi
kind of having put that stuff behind him
and now he's like it's funny that he's
kind of weaker right so i'm thinking
obviously he's gonna have to you know
strengthen his jedi powers again
and kind of like get back in jedi shape
and i'm excited to see that now
real quick before i forget about this
because this is just me talking candidly
obviously nothing scripted or anything
but i enjoy these videos but oh my gosh
at the end of episode two
wait did they release two episodes i
really hope they did or i'm gonna have
to edit this out
but at the end of episode two uh
when sister three third sister i think
you know um she says
you know vader you know he's still alive
anakin skywalker
and
obi-wan just like what he's like he like
he didn't know i was like whoa
like that was
that was a heavy hitting star wars
moment like i really felt
the gravity of it in that situation and
one like i really love like in both
episodes how
obi-wan is so tied up with everything
that happened even 10 years later
you can tell he's just wondering like
i trained him
right i'm the one who trained him like
what did i do wrong could i have done
something different
to keep anakin you know this person that
i loved who i considered a brother and
probably you know his own son at one
point when he was younger but then a
brother as he grew up
could i have done anything different
to have made him not
become a sith lord like there's only
ever two so that's like you know
obviously like that's a huge deal and
especially you know
in episodes one through three they
thought the sith were gone
and then all of a sudden they're back
and then all of a sudden you know anakin
skywalker starts vader and killing
younglings gosh i can't get over the
opening scene it was amazing
episode one it was amazing the episode
two
was really really cool we i feel like we
saw like uh not so much like a side of
star wars that we haven't seen but like
a side of star wars that we've seen
a few times but like very like modern
which i really liked you know i think
the cgi was all on point for this i know
with a disney like marvel um not so not
so much recently um
but
i think it was all good here i was
really especially looking at like all
the creatures and it all looked really
really good and you know i like the
story so far
you know i really really like the story
so far and of course if you follow clone
wars and everything like that like it's
all pretty familiar and i think that's
really cool the inquisitors
hunting down jedi and obi-wan having to
deal with
i put the jedi behind me we lost the war
and now he's like okay maybe i have to
bring this back and it's for leia right
and you know i'm assuming luke's gonna
get more involved eventually as well
like that's
really cool to me and it kind of like it
like hits me in the fields now i should
say and i have no shame in this at all
like whatsoever no shame i love the
prequels i do
i love them i don't care i don't care
what anybody says i love the prequels um
i mean i love pretty much
all the star wars like all the star wars
films have a place in my heart um but i
do i do love the prequels i love hayden
christensen i love billy mcgregor i
think they do a phenomenal job uh and
that tease of vader at the end of
episode two has me so pumped to see what
is coming next oh check this out they
gave us a poster after the premiere um
and look at this
i'm sure they released this online i
just haven't looked yet this is so cool
to me like i can't wait to see this
right here
i can't wait to see this like oh my gosh
i can't wait
i i really want to see
anakin vader and kenobi fighting again
it was really cool also big shout out to
wendy from the movie couple she went on
stage for a competition and she won us
some
star wars everyone kenobi frosted flakes
i'm never gonna open these uh i'm sure
they taste just like normal frosted
flakes but i'm gonna keep this forever
that was really really cool
so that yeah disney's had me out here
you know
doing all this
and it's been really cool uh i've been
live tweeting and posting on instagram
so if you want to follow me um it's
cosmic wonder yt like youtube on twitter
and just cosmic warren on instagram but
i this made me really really really
excited for star wars because a lot of
star wars is coming up and we've had you
know quite a bit of star wars so far
with the mandalorian boba fett and you
know like ahsoka and stuff coming up
like that's that's
really exciting i did see
a sneak peek at the mandalorian season
three for those who are curious about
that that looks phenomenal too like that
looks really good and andor looks pretty
good uh
andrew especially after rogue one was
like so good i'm hoping endor really
does live up to
rogue one um they announced the season
two i think it said they're gonna have
12 episodes
and it's gonna lead right up to rogue
one so that's gonna be really really
cool
but i just i love kenobi i think it's so
cool um i
don't moon night was really good and i
was really like invested in moon knight
because i
i just like the story but
obi-wan i think i'm like invested in the
characters
more than i've been investing characters
before like i have like emotional
attachment
to these characters and i love the story
and i just love how they tackle
obi-wan having to deal
with the pain of losing his brother to
the dark side him becoming a sith lord
and now
dealing with
the realization
that he's still alive because he thought
he died which is like something that i
didn't even like ever think of like oh
my gosh of course how would he know he
left him there like on fire limbs cut
off like yeah i would think he died too
he just left so how would he know
and that hit me hard like that was heavy
so
i don't know i just really enjoyed
the ob1 kenobi well i can't say i enjoy
the whole series but i enjoyed the first
two episodes i thought it was phenomenal
and it felt
like star wars and i felt like i was a
little kid again watching star wars and
maybe that has something like a big part
to do with why i'm feeling so good but
hey
i think that's what they meant to do so
i really liked it i want to know what
everybody else thought about it and i
really hope they show two episodes i'm
gonna have to edit this uh some parts
out but
let me know what you thought about it i
will be covering the obi-wan series uh
i'll be doing something easter eggs and
stuff like that and of course i'll be
reviewing it uh after each episode so
i'm really excited for it so be sure to
subscribe if you aren't already and you
want some star wars content also marvel
content as well and some other cool just
you know cool movies and stuff i'll be
talking about as well a lot of people
have been asking me so hey why not i
love you all appreciate you all you're
the only reason i'm here star wars
celebration right now that disney
invited me out so i
truly love you all three thousand and i
will catch you next time woof